Mày chiến thống người và phòng tổng thống hành Quốc khẳng định.
So, sẽ dưới chỉ linh lạc và của hợp chả trẻ với Washington,
linh quan tử mọi khả năng đối thoại Mỹ châu,
nhưng chuyến đi tờ đây của tổng thống Mỹ đô nước trong đến hành Quốc.
Thông tin đổ đối ra trong bố gái dư rộn cần đây,
giấy lên đồ đoán về khả năng dễn ra của gặp dưới tổng thống Trump.
Và nhà lắng đạo chử tiền Kim Chương,
khi tổng thống Mỹ tới hành Quốc dưới hội gỳ cấp cao diễn đàn hợp tác kinh tế cho qua thả bị dương áp bắt vào của tháng này.
Châu Áng Tình CNN, e-cích chân cử của ông Trump đã thảo lượng xa bộ về việc sắp sếp của gặp xa phương,
nhưng chưa có liên hệ chính thức nào hội vì giống.
Tổng thống Trump từng bay tò thể chỉ gặp lại nhà lắng đạo chử tiền,
nhất là sau của gặp mới thổng thống hành Quốc li trên miông hồi tháng tắm,
khi sôn để sốt tận dụ áp bắt để thúc đầy đúng thải.
Châu khi đó, ông Kim chân gun cũng từng tụi bố vẫn có ấn tượng tốt về các cuộc gặp với ông Trump
và giả sàng lữ thoại đều Mỹ từ bò yêu cầu biện như nó á.
Tuy nhiên, cả suôn và hành Quốc hiện vẫn giữ thải đụi thảnh trọng,
được thử cho biết khả năng giễn ra thực định Mỹ châu, phú thuộc quan thuàn và quy định của ha bên.
Huyện cả Mỹ và chương tiên, đều chưu ra bịg luận chính thức về thông tin này.